Superhero movies play a huge role in pop culture
today and when a new movie is revealed, fans
need to know almost immediately who the studios
have cast for their favorite characters.
With so many actors clamoring to play these
iconic heroes and villains, changes are often
made at the drop of a hat.
One day, you hear your favorite actor will
play your favorite comic book character, and
then the next day, they’re out.
When you hear of Christian Bale as Batman,
Andrew Garfield as Spider-Man, Henry Cavill
as Superman, Hugh Jackman as Wolverine and
Robert Downey Jr. as Iron Man, it’s not
hard to imagine them playing the parts since
all the actors killed it in their roles, respectively.
But these characters could have easily been
played by other actors.
In this list we will take a look at some A-listers
who lost out to portraying classic comic characters.
Check out these 10 actors who ALMOST became
a Marvel superhero.
And make sure you subscribe to our YouTube
channel see more videos just like this one.
Emily Blunt as Black Widow
Scarlett Johansson has impressed Marvel fans
as the former KGB spy turned SHIELD agent
Natasha Romanova, but believe it or not, she
wasn’t the first choice for the role.
Emily Blunt was actually set to play the role
of Black Widow.
She literally had the role in “Iron Man
2,” but due to contract obligations with
Fox, she had to drop out.
Instead of being our Black Widow she co-starred
in “Gulliver’s Travels” alongside Jack
Black.
Dougray Scott as Wolverine
We have seen Hugh Jackman as the clawed and
rugged hero Wolverine for 17 years now, but
it would surprise you to know he wasn’t
the original choice.
In Bryan Singer’s first “X-Men” film,
Dougray Scott was cast as Logan.
However, the British actor was forced to drop
out due to a scheduling conflict.
Scott was reportedly hand-picked by Tom Cruise
to play the villain in “Mission: Impossible
II,” which made it impossible for the actor
to stay onboard with “X-Men.”
Viggo Mortensen as Wolverine
Again, it’s hard to imagine Wolverine not
being played by Hugh Jackman but there are
a few names that had potential to do the role
justice.
Aside from Russell Crowe, who was Singer’s
first choice, and Dougray Scott, who was cast
in the part, another actor was a strand of
hair close to becoming Wolverine.
That is none other than Aragorn himself: Viggo
Mortensen.
Luckily we’ve seen Mortensen in action as
Aragorn so picturing him as Logan is no problem
at all.
While Mortensen never had the chance to play
the regenerative clawed-mutant, the actor
will always be remembered as the Ranger of
the North, Aragorn, from “Lord of the Rings.”
Jim Caviezel as Cyclops
Before James Marsden was cast as Cyclops in
Singer’s “X-Men,” the role was offered
to Jim Caviezel.
The actor apparently beat out a long list
of A-list actors who auditioned for the role
including: Thomas Jane, Owen Wilson, Edward
Norton, Jude Law and a bunch of others.
Unfortunately, Caviezel had to drop out due
to his commitment to the film “Frequency.”
Apparently, this move also disqualified him
from getting the Superman role in Singer’s
“Superman Returns.”
Guess Singer didn’t want Jesus playing the
man of steel.
Tom Cruise as Iron Man
Before Robert Downey Jr. landed the role as
billionaire playboy Tony Stark, Tom Cruise
was a frontrunner to play the mechanical hero.
The actor and the studio execs were in talks
for a while, but Cruise eventually lost interest
in the film and walked away.
He just didn’t feel like it was a project
he could commit himself to 100 percent.
It all worked out for the best as Downey Jr.
is perhaps the best Tony Stark Marvel could
get.
Jon Favreau also looked into casting Clive
Owen and Sam Rockwell in the role.
John Krasinski as Captain America
Chris Evans has dominated the role of Steve
Rogers aka Captain America, but there was
another actor close to nabbing the role.
John Krasinski — more popularly know as
Jim from “The Office” — was the highest
name of the list of actors to play Cap.
He beat out actors like Channing Tatum, Ryan
Phillippe, Mike Vogel and Garrett Hedlund.
Then from out of nowhere, Chris Evans jumped
into the role without even having to audition
and the rest is history.
Channing Tatum as Thor
A lot of people know that Tom Hiddleston auditioned
as Loki and brothers Liam and Chris Hemsworth
battled against each other for the role of
Thor.
But little know that actor and dancer Channing
Tatum was a top choice for the God of Thunder.
The Magic Mike star reportedly met with director
Kenneth Branagh to talk about the role.
All went well, but the Irish director ended
up going with the eldest Hemsworth.
Unfortunately, the hammer Mjölnir is out
of reach for Tatum, but if you’re dying
to see him as a superhero you’ll get your
chance when he plays the mutant Gambit.
Sigourney Weaver as Emma Frost
Before Bryan Singer departed from “X-Men:
The Last Stand,” the director planned to
introduce Emma Frost, also known as The White
Queen.
The initial plan was to bring Frost in as
an empath villainess who would manipulate
Jean Grey and later on join Magneto to help
undo the heroes.
But when Singer left to focus on “Superman
Returns,” so did Sigourney Weaver’s appearance
as Emma Frost.
The director wanted Weaver as the villainess,
but her appearance was scrapped from the script.
The character was brought back for “X-Men:
First Class,” but January Jones was given
the role.
Rachael Leigh Cook as Rogue
While Anna Paquin didn’t give us the butt
kicking, tough as nails Rogue from the comics,
she did bring the southern belle charm to
life.
But it will interest you to know Bryan Singer
offered the role to another actress first.
“She’s All That” star Racheal Leigh
Cook was offered the role of Rogue before
Paquin in the 2000 “X-Men” movie.
The actress turned it down because she didn't
like the idea of seeing too much CGI in the
film and went on to star in the musical comedy
“Josie and the Pussycats” instead.
A lot of actors as Spider-Man
Spidey is arguably one of the most recognized
Marvel superheroes around, so it’s no surprise
lots of actors jump at the chance to play
the web-slinger.
Many big name actors were in talks to play
Spider-Man including Tom Cruise, Leonardo
DiCaprio, Jude Law and Heath Ledger.
Even actors who were in previous Spider-Man
movies wanted the big role for themselves.
James Franco read for the lead in Sam Raimi’s
“Spider-Man” but was ultimately beaten
to the prize by Toby Maguire.
Franco confessed that he was disappointed
when the director called him to let him know
he didn’t get the part, though he softened
the blow when he instead offered the him the
part of Harry Osborn, son of the Green Goblin
and Peter Parker's best friend.
Harry Potter star Daniel Radcliffe recently
revealed he was interested in becoming the
new MCU Spider-Man.
While giving his fellow countryman Tom Holland
a congratulations on landing the part, he
talked about how he wanted to be the new hero
but also mentioned how it was now out of reach.
"I would have made a good Spider-Man, but
the boat has sailed on that one,” said Radcliffe.
“I'm not sure if I'd sign up for something
that was another seven or eight films or ten
years, but a shorter franchise, yeah.”
What do you think of our list?
Are there any Marvel superheroes we’ve missed?
Join the discussion in the comments below,
and make sure to join the notification squad
to stay up to date on all our content.